[Applause]
We arrived Enrique bromas de la serna I am a
soccer narrator from Argentina 1978
narrating 11 world cups Qatar will be
my 12th world championship
and he says that narrating
sports commentary would be my life
after an opportunity I had in
Guadalajara
in the League of  Club of
Mexico City and the owner told me that he would
recommend someone and suddenly I said, well,
I am going to recommend it to myself I
recommended myself and that's where my great
opportunity came
[Applause]
in December 76 in 77 they called me from
television  of Televisa without radio and in 78 I
was already a year 10 months later
narrating my first World Cup in
Argentina 68 the Mexican narrative
also Argentina the Colombian the
Chilean is characterized by the passion for
the energy for the force in the voice for
the cry  of the long goal for delivering all
the passion all the fiber of being in each
play
the World Cups for me means in the
most important moment of any
rapporteur of any game  player of
any professional Real coach
when I hear the children repeat my
phrases not only in Mexico it has happened to me in
Argentina in Colombia in Chile the
United States in Ecuador El Salvador in
Honduras in Guatemala in many places
because it goes up many years
[Music]
the  Donkey knows more than you to
narrate a goal in the World Cup, El Éxtasis,
above all, if you scored a goal from my
Mexican teams, narrating any
is important, but my Mexican team
is El Éxtasis.
the hairs and one lives do not
separate the dogs that I do not have but it
is sensational
[Applause]